مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري للمجريات الميدانيه لحرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه نرحب بالمحلل
العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري
مرحبا بك سيد فايز سانطي بالحديث بتلك
الجمله التي قالها المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي اننا نخوض معركه مركبه ومعقده
في غزه نعم اي هذا التصريح يحمل شيء من
الدقه والموضوعيه لماذا لانه هذه الحرب هي
غير متناظره وخارج الاطر التقليديه
لداره المعارك هو يقاتل اي
جماعات
عسكريه منظمه بطريقه مختلفه بامكانات
مختلفه بمقاربات مختلفه عندما نتحدث عن
الحرب التقليديه نتحدث عن جيوش متقابله
تمتلك نفس الاسلحه تمتلك تقريبا عقائد
قتاليه وان اختلفت حتى ما بين العقيده
الشرقيه والغربيه وان اختلفت لكن الاطر
العامه للعقائد القتاليه الى حد ما
متماثله لكن الاختلاف التفاصيل لكن عندما
تدخل في اولا حرب لام متناظره انت تقاتل
جماعات مسلحه بطريقه مختلفه ولا واضافه
على ذلك في مناطق مبنيه وبعد ذلك وقبل ذلك
في انفاق اذا اصبح عندك ثلاثه اختلافات
جوهريه رئيسيه ما بين خوض معارك تقليديه
ومعارك غير تقليديه العدو مختلف الجغرافيا
مختلفه و الابعاد المكانيه للحرب مختلفه
النتيجه هي اعداد كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الى حد ان مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه وصفت
يوم امس بانه الاقصى في في هذه الحرب بعد
الاعلان عن مقتل 15 ضابطا وجنديا كتائب
القسام وزعت مجموعه من المشاهد اليوم
تحدثنا عنها سابقا لكن من المفيد اعاده
شرحها بدقه اكثر خصوصا مع الاعلان عن
ارتفاع اعداد القتلى من الجنود والضباط
الاسرائيليين يعني الاعلان تقريبا اخر
اعلان للناطق باسم كتاب القسام تحدث عن 48
قتيل خلال اربعه ايام هذا اخر اعلان وتحدث
عن 35 اليه وتحدث عن عشرات
الجرحى لم يحدد العدد لكن رقم 48 رقما
مؤكدا هذا هذا الفيلم
اي المميز فيه اين
وقع يق ال وقع وقع في وقع في مكانين نعم
في الزاويه الشماليه الغربيه لبيت لاهيا
بين بيت لاهيا والعطا
اللهب الم الزراعيه وصلها جيش الاحتلال في
اليوم الاول والجزء الاخر منه واللقطه
الاخرى وقعت في بيت حانون والتي اعلن
انسحابه منها مساء هذا اليوم بعد ان تحدث
عن السيطره وهجي تحدث عن السيطره واشار
الى هذه المناطق انسحب منها السؤال هل
انسحب منها من اجل اعاده التموضع
والحديث عن المنطقه العاجله سسال سنسال
بدقه عن ابعاد هذا الانسحاب لكن كنت تشير
الى ان اهميه هذه المشاهد انها صورت
واحداث حصلت في بيت لاهيه وفي بيت حنون
لماذا مهمه من هذه الزاويه لانه تعطيني
مؤشر واضح جدا ان ان مفهوم
السيطره غير متفق على تعريفه يعني عندما
هاجار يتحدث عن مفهوم السيطره هو يتحدث
خارج التعريفات المعتمده في الكليات
العسكريه العالميه المتطوره امريكا وروسيا
والصين وغيرها هناك هناك مصطلحات تحمل نفس
المعنى وان اختلفت اللغه عندما اقول
السيطره تعني السيطره الحقيقيه بكامل
ابعادها يعني بمعنى اخر حتى تمر في مراحل
حتى تصل الى الهولدينغ او عمليه وضع اليد
على المنطقه انت تمر في
مقاربه المعارك المتحركه و و بالتالي
عمليات اخلاء والقاء قبض يعني يعني هذه
المشاهد هذه المشاهد تضحد نظريه سيط طيب
لا يوجد سيطره لكن كما قلت عندما تبعنا
هذه الصور فيما بعد اعلن عن الانسحاب من
بيت حنون من وجهه نظر عسكريه برايك هل هو
الضغط العسكري الذي دفع الى الانس كلا
الامرين كلا الامرين اولا بس قبل ان نحكي
عن عن ال الانسحاب عفوا نشير الى ان هذه
الصور لاحد الانفاق لاحد الانفاق هذه
صور وزعها الجيش الاسرائيلي جباليه نعم
نعم هذه صوره لاحد الانفاق في منطقه
جباليه و وزعها الجيش الاسرائيلي هي تعطي
انطباع او تصور مبدئي عن ما
هي اسرائيل تقول مترو حماس ام وفي مكان
اخر قالت اكبر من انفاق مدينه لندن
هذا تقريبا هم اللي يؤكدوا تلك المقوله
لانه هذا النفق او مجموعه الانفاق التي
عرضت هي تبين مدى التباين ما بين هذه
الانفاق بعضها انفاق ضيقه تشكل ممرات
بعضها نقاط
ل مستودعات اسلحه بعضها اماكن لتناول
الطعام بعضها اماكن ل للنوم يوجد
بها كولر ماء يوجد يعني كانهم يقولوا غزه
هي مدينه تحت مدينه وهذا القول اعتدنا على
لكن هذه الصور عندما يوزعها الجيش
الاسرائيلي كانه يريد ان يقول باننا نحقق
اهدافا ونحقق مكاسب عسكريه على الارض
بدليل اننا اكتشفنا هذه الانفاق ودخلناها
نعم هو دخل الى مناطق
والخارطة نقول ل لدى القوات المدافعه لا
تزال امكانيه شن عمليات انا بدات حديثي
بالمعركه اللام متناظره يقاتل ضد جماعات
بتدريب معين
بمقاربات تئبر ومقاتلي القسام والجهاد
وغيرها لا يتواجدوا في المكان بنفس بصوره
دائمه 24 ساعه لا نتحدث عن موقع عسكري نحن
نتحدث عن اشخاص موجودين في هذا النفق
يخرجوا منه يؤدي مهمه يعود اليه فيم
الفتره ما بين العمليه والعمليه لا يكون
تواجد لقوات القسام وبالتالي اذا عثر على
فتحه نفق لديه الامكانات ولديه القدره ان
يدخل به يستخدم الكلاب يستخدم الروبوت
يستخدم امور عديده وبالتالي هو دخل احد
الانفاق كم طول هذا النفق والى اين يصل
هذا النفق هذا في منطقه جباليه هل هو
يمثلك في هذا اليوم الجانب الاسرا الكيان
الاسرائيلي يتحدث انه كنا نعتقد ان
الانفاق تمتد مع ما بين 100 الى 200 م
الان لدينا القناعه بانها ما بين 500 الى
570 م وهذا الرقم استخدمنا منذ بدايه
المعركه عندما
شاهدنا مشاهد القسام قبل قليل المشاهد
التي عرضت قبل
قليل وكنت تتحدث عن الجيش الاسرائيلي لا
يسيطر بالمعنى
الفعلي بشكل او باخر هل يمكن ان نقول ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي فوق الارض وال المقاومين
تحت الارض في نفس المكان قد يكون ويجب ان
يكون ام الان الم تدخل القوات الاسرائيليه
من السياج حتى وصلت الى جباليه واطراف
يعني السيطره قد تكون فوق الارض فقط نعم
نعم يعني الان تحركت القوات الجيش
الاحتلال وعبرت السياج و
ودمرت بيت سنضرب مثال في بيت حانون ام
وصلت دمرت بيت حانون لم يعد فيها بناء
واحد قائم تعدت منها ومن الطريق التي
غربها مع شارع صلاح الدين وصلت الى ابراج
زايد الشيخ زايد تعدت الابراج وتعدت بيت
لاهيه لنحاول تطويقها ولم يستطع تعدت بيت
لاهيه وصل الى عمق او اطراف منطقه ج مخيم
جباليه ومنطقه جباليه هذه المنطقه
المقاتلين الذي يقاتل في بيت حانون هو
يوجد تقريبا على مسار
في بعض الحالات اكثر من 2 ك م من مقدمه
القوات نعم وهو يقاتل كما يقول كما قلنا
مرارا خلف خطوط العدو اذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي فوق الارض والمقاتل
الفلسطيني في الانفاق تحت الارض عمود
شاقوليا في نفس
النقطه لنعود
الى نقطه الانسحاب موضوع الانسحاب مهم
يعني الاعلان جيش الاحتلال والحديث عن
الانسحاب من بعض المناطق هو يتحدث عن
اعاده تموضع
اي الانسحاب من بيت حنون كنت سالتك ان كان
تحت الضغط او هو فعلا في اطار خطه عسكريه
جديده اسرائيليه للتموضع في اماكن محدده
في الشمال يعني الان اذا اراد التموضع هو
سيتمو اذا استطاع في المناطق الزراعيه من
اطراف بيت حانون بيت لاهيه الع عطاطره
وصول ل شارع الرشيد هذه المنطقه الى
الشمال منها كلها باعتبار مناطق زراعيه
فبد يا هو تحدث عن انشاء هذه المنطقه
العازله فيريد ان يتموضع بها الان انسحب
من بيت حنون الى اين انسحب لا نعلم حتى
هذه اللحظه هل انسحب تراجع مسافه لانه
المسافه 2200 متر تقريبا هل انسحب ب الى
1.5 ك م هل انسحب الى منطقه اخرى هل سحب
القوات لتتحرك باتجاه جبهه التفاح التي
ستبدا يبدا القتال بها يمكن في هذه الليله
اذا هناك تساؤلات الان هو لماذا انسحب
انسحب
اولا لجمله عوال السبع عوامل ساحاول ان
ارتبها السبب الاول عدم فقدانه القدره على
ادامه زخم الهجوم في مناطق الاشتباك كامله
نعم وبالتالي هو الان بدا بسحب هذه القوات
سحبها من بيت حانون سحبها من تل الهواء
سحبها من جنوب مخيم
الشاطئ الان هو قسر خطوط الاشتباك
وبالتالي يكون لديه القدره على اعاده
تركيز
وتموضع القوه لتوظيفها في قواطع ضيقه هذا
يعطيه الفرصه على زياده ما يمكن يطلق عليه
الكثافه الناريه الكثافه العدديه و محاوله
تجديد سيطرته على مصطلح ادامه الزخم السبب
الثاني للانسحاب كان واضحا جدا الم يتم
الحديث عن تسريح عشرات الالاف من العام من
الاحتياط هؤلاء لانه بسبب الضغوط
الاقتصاديه الامر الثالث هو ادرك يقينا
رغم المكابره في التصريحات السياسيه وهناك
خلافات الان ما بين حتى في في مجلس الحرب
ما بين وزير الدفاع ونتنياهو وهناك
انتقادات من
نائب رئيس اركان سابق وا مدير شعبه
الاستخبارات السابق يطالب نتنياهو بتحديد
الاهداف بتحديد اهداف العمليه العسكريه
يجب ان نتفق على تحديد الهدف هل الهدف
القضاء على حماس هل الهدف نزع سلاح حماس
هل الهدف اطلاق الرهائن ما هو الهدف هذا
التناقض جمله واحده هذا التناقض ادى الى
عمليه ارتباك واضحه جدا هو ينسحب من منطقه
يعزز في منطقه لهذا السبب هذا الارتباك
ادى ارتفاع اعداد الخسائر تحديدا هذا ما
كنت ساسال ك عنه يعني بموازاه الحديث عن
الانسحاب من بيت حانون مثلا في الشمال
نراه
اي يحاول التوغل بشكل اضافي في مناطق
الجنوب معارك في مناطق خانيونس وانت قلت
ايضا قبل قليل انه قد يبدا القتال في حي
التفاح بمعنى انه ينسحب من مكان ويزخر
المعركه في مكان يحاول ان يطور هجومه من
اتجاهات جديده الان اذا تحدثنا عن مخيم
جباليا وجباليا هو فشل في اقتحام المنطقه
من جهه الفالوجه رغم انه الفالوجه تعتبر
منطقه مرتفعه تؤمن له الرصد والمراقبه و
وعمليه ضبط ضبط النيران بالنسبه للمدفعيه
الان لم يستطع ان
يحقق بيت حانون اصبحت مشكله معظم الافلام
تاتي من بيت حانون ومن جحر الديك وبالتالي
هو يبدو انه اعاد انتشار قواته لا اقول
تموضعها اعاد انتشارها كمرحله سابقه على
اعاده التموضع من اجل من اجل تجريب اي ان
يجد ثغره نقطه ضعف معينه فالان بدا القتال
بدل ان يكون من الشمال الغربي لمخيم
جباليه وجباليا اتجه باتجاه الشرق والشمال
الشرقي عله يجد اي منطقه ضعيفه من حيث
القدره الدفاعيه ويجرب حظه في تحقيق لانه
هو يحاول ان يقسم المقسم يحاول ان يفصل
مخيم جباليه عن جباليه لانه اذا استطاع ان
يحقق ذلك يصبح على مقربه من مدينه غزه
القديمه سنعود
ل للحديث عن هذه الصور بشكل مفصل بعد هذا
السؤال المتعلق باننا نشاهد
اي هذه المعارك في حنون في الشمال تحديدا
في الوقت الذي يقول فيه جيش الاحتلال بانه
استطاع تفكيك القياده الشماليه لحركه حماس
كيف يمكن ان نفهم معارك في الشمال بهذا
الشكل والقياده مفككه حسب قول الجيش
الاسرائيلي اخر دفعه صواريخ اطلقت من
الشجاعيه يعني يعني انا اجبت بجمله مختصره
عندما يكون زخم القتال واقوى المعارك كانت
تجري في الشجاعيه اطلقت الصواريخ في اخر
رشقه من الشجاعيه كيف تطلق ومسافه النيران
يمكن ان تكون على بعد مئات من الامتار هذا
يعني ان القياده موجوده القياده فاعله لا
تزال تتحكم في خيوط اللعبه بصوره متقنه
تمرر تتلقى التعليمات التوجيهات من ي من
بدون ذكر اسماء من المستوى السياسي تنزل
الى القاد العسكري هيئه ركن العمليات ي
يخصص ال المجموعه التي ستطلق والمكان الذي
سيتم منه الاطلاق وبالتالي اذا قنوات
الاتصال والتواصل والتغذيه الراجعه موجوده
يعني انت تعتبر بان اطلاق الصواريخ
والاماكن التي تطلق منها هي عباره عن
رسائل عسكريه وسياسيه بنفس الوقت نعم انا
انا انا ادير لعبتي بالطريقه التي اشاء هي
كلاعبي شطرنج امم انا العب بالحجاره
البيضاء التي بين يديك وانت عليك ان تلعب
بالحجاره الس سوداء وبالتالي انا ساتقدم
عليك بخطوه دائما طيب ل نعد الى الصور من
جديد نشاهد استهداف
اي جنود الاحتلال في اماكن ومنازل تحصنوا
فيها بعضها تم استهدافهم بالقنص بقذائف تي
بي جي وايضا بالتفجير تابعنا ذلك ولكن اود
ان اسال هنا وكنت ربما سالت ك سابقا عنها
الحركه التي كان يتحرك بها جنود الاحتلال
في هذه المنطقه يعني الحركه اعتقد انها
حركه عسكريه لا استطيع ان اقول لا لماذا
لانه خرجوا من منطقه خلفيه ظهروا على شكل
جماعات ساروا بخط منفرد ساروا بمسافات
بينيه وبالتالي اتخذوا الاحتياطات الكامله
لكنهم لم لم يكن لديهم منظومه استخباريه
تعطيهم المعلومه الدقيقه عن مدى الامان في
هذه المنط المطقه فبالتالي هم كانوا
يراقبوا ويتحركوا على شكل خط منفرد دخلوا
الى المنطقه لكن الجانب الاخر كان لديه
القدره الاستطلاعيه باكثر نضجا
راقبهم تابعهم دخلوا الى المنطقه الى الى
المبنى بعد ذلك تم استهدافهم بصاروخ
كورنيت ولاحظنا اثر ذلك الانفجار اللقطه
الاخرى كانت مختلفه لكن كانت فيها شيء من
الغرابه
المجموعه كانت تحضر المبنى للتفجير وعمليه
تحضير المبنى للتفجير يعتمد على عوامل
كثيره لكنه يحتاج الى وقت لماذا لانه
امامه خيارين اما ان يضاعف كميه المتفجرات
وبالتالي يكون استهلاك عالي لها خاصه انه
ينفذ عمليات تدمير كبيره او ان يقوم
بتجهيز الحشوات هندسيا هنا ندخل في بعد لا
داعي للتفصيل فيه لانه قد يبدو غير مفهوم
للمشاهدين الان يتم توضيع الحشوات بناء
على التصميم الهندسي للمبنى باوزان معينه
بابعاد معينه الان اما ان يضاعف كميه
الحشوات او ان ان يبذل جهدا اضافيا في
تحضير اكياس رمل ليضعها عليها ليكون تاثير
التفجير باتجاه الجدار نعم هذا يحتاج الى
وقت والوقت هنا يعتمد على عدد المجموعه
العامله وعلى طبيعه المبنى وقد ياخذ ساعات
لاحظ المراقب في الجهه الاخرى بقي في
مكانه بوضعيه ما ويترقب اللحظه المناسبه
وقام بمهاجمتهم ف ف فقتل وجرح المجموعه
التي كانت تحضر للتفجير شكرا جزيلا لك
اللواء فيز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي بذلك مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام
هذه النافذه التحليليه للاوضاع الميدانيه
في قطاع غزه نعود من جديد الى سلمى